[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a korean comedy sci-fi film
called i am
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the opening scene a young university
student yoon wu wakes up from a
nightmare he reaches for a water bottle
on his nightstand and a hand pushes it
towards him initially yoonwu doesn't
notice it and gulps down the water but
then he looks to the side to see a girl
sitting in a corner staring right at him
yoon-woo almost chokes on the water at
the sight but the girl remained seated
with a blank expression on her face on
hearing the noise you would sister minji
comes to the room with a baseball bat
but is too scared to attack the girl she
jumps on the bed with her brother
assuming that the stranger is a ghost
they only calm down when their father dr
cha enters the room he explains that the
girl is with him and gathers them all in
the living room to talk the strange girl
walks around the room inspecting the
curtains as the siblings watch her in
confusion minji wants to know who the
girl is but yoon woo couldn't care less
his relationship with his father is not
ideal dr cha is a scientist who always
submerged himself in work and hardly
paid attention to his kids hence yoon
woo resents him and his work when ming
urges him to speak the doctor reveals
that the girl is an advanced android he
has conducted research on ai his entire
life he even created the narrator of
mystery recapped and this girl is the
result of it before he can explain
further the girl picks up an entire
table with only one hand to retrieve a
ball from under it minji and yoon wu are
left stunned to say the least dr cha
introduces the girl as the best known
robot to mankind a.d number one she
throws a peace sign presenting herself
to them a.d number one has a complex
system and is highly advanced however
she is currently in her learning phase
and has an intelligence level similar to
a high school student she is also in the
last stage of self-examination hence dr
cha wants his children to keep her with
them for a few weeks to see how she
adapts yoonwu is absolutely against the
idea but minji wants to help her father
she asks him to rest assured promising
to take care of the robot after dr cha
leaves she talks to the robot who
replies to all of her questions minji is
amazed by the ai's intelligence she
names her annie and officially welcomes
her into the family the following
morning minji brings annie to the high
school where she teaches she introduces
her to the class as an american transfer
student and her cousin the youngsters
are excited to have a foreigner among
them after school minji brings annie to
yoon woo's college and asks him to drive
her home she is going on a business trip
for a day hence yoon woo has to
reluctantly help the robot in only a day
annie has grown attached to minji she
asks her not to go on the trip but minji
promises to bring her something pretty
and walks away annie also notices that
yoon woo doesn't want to take her home
to avoid bothering him she sends him
back to class promising to get home
safely at night yunu can barely fall
asleep disturbed by a strange feeling
about his father he calls dr cha who
claims that he is just around the
neighborhood and will come to see any
soon right after the call someone
attacks dr cha and takes his phone away
the following day at school the class
president ji yoon and her best friend
tai hee make friends with annie although
annie is usually quiet and
non-responsive they seem to enjoy her
company when she doesn't speak she
analyzes the girl's behavioral patterns
and is fascinated by the way they giggle
somewhere else yoon-woo is on a date
with his girlfriend sulgi they're
approached by dr cha's colleague kevin
he is worried about the doctor because
he hasn't been picking up his phone
since last night kevin is also minji's
boyfriend and is quite close to yoon woo
yoonwu promises to tell him if he gets a
hold of his father later that day minji
finds annie making faces in the mirror
she is curious about why people smile
and what happiness is the questions are
too advanced for minji to explain she
dismisses the conversation by saying
that annie will know when she feels it
kind of a low blow thing to say to an
android when yoon woo returns home and
he watches minji drag him by his ear to
the dinner table she keeps the memory
safe to use for later yoon woo is
annoyed that annie is with them at the
dinner table when she can't even eat
minji on the other hand declares that
she's a part of the family and deserves
to be there the comment makes annie feel
a warm emotion for the first time but
she doesn't yet recognize what the
feeling is in the following scene minji
and kevin meet at a cafe for a date
kevin is still worried about dr cha's
sudden absence but since minji is used
to it since childhood she doesn't think
much of it when kevin mentions an ai
robot project minji brings him home to
meet annie in the meantime annie is
returning home from school when she
comes across a man in all black clothing
he is the same guy who attacked dr cha
last night before he can get to her yoon
woo hides her behind a bush after the
stranger goes away annie claims that dr
cha said the man is not a good person
meaning he already knew someone was
after them later annie meets kevin and
calls him by his name it turns out that
he was dr cha's assistant during the
last phase of developing the robot he
wants to take annie to the lab but she
refuses to come wanting to stay with
minji instead the couple gets into a
slight argument on who gets to keep the
robot before minji asks annie to go
inside at home annie watches bts's
performance on the tv claiming that her
friends talk about the boy band a lot
she also learns the dance choreography
while she's at it minji supports her new
hobby and encourages her to watch the
following day at school a guy gives
annie a bunch of gifts and asks her out
on a date but the school bully who has a
crush on the same guy threatens her to
stay away when her best friends take
annie's side they try to hit the girls
annie with her iron hands stops them
easily minji sees them arguing and
punishes them all
ji yoon tai he and annie are made to
stand outside with their hands up until
they turn sore when no one is around the
girls decide to skip school for the day
although skeptical and he joins them and
has a blast they go to an arcade where
she wins every round in a claw machine
then to a karaoke place where she dances
to the songs she learned from tv a few
hours later they are walking through a
park when annie smiles for the first
time thanks to her friends she finally
understands what happiness is
the next morning yoon woo dreams of
annie running away from danger and wakes
up to her right above him she is there
to call him outside for breakfast when
he refuses to eat she grabs his ears
mimicking minji and making him laugh
that day he takes her to a cafe to meet
his girlfriend silgy as the couple
flirts annie feels a pang of jealousy
for the first time in the heat of the
moment she calls silgy ugly in the
following scene annie and yoonwu are at
home they awkwardly sit beside each
other and talk about the events of the
day on being asked why she was rude to
seulgi earlier she claims that she feels
weird around yoon woo he dismisses it as
a programming error but silently admits
to himself that he also feels different
when he is with her whoa
meanwhile kevin comes to pick up minji
but she refuses to talk to him she is
disappointed that he looks at annie as a
thing when she resembles a human more
than an object before minji storms off
he reveals that today is annie's first
birthday minji immediately calls yoonwu
and asks him to pick up annie after
school she wants him to keep her busy
until she can prepare a surprise
birthday party for her yoon woo does is
told and brings annie on a shopping
spree he buys her everything she wants
then brings her to a park upon returning
home she is surprised by kevin taihee
minji and ji yoon with a birthday cake
she cuts the cake and is overjoyed that
they care about her so much the
following day at school annie and her
group are selected for a relay race at
the sports meet next week they practice
all afternoon and teach annie the rules
and he mimics them and pretends to be
tired to seem human after that she
excuses herself to recharge privately in
the classroom tai hee walks into the
room to see her plugged into the charger
and freaks out fortunately minji arrives
there on time and calms her down at home
annie questions minji why she is
different from her friends she is
confused about her existence but minji
has no way to make her understand
without making her feel like the odd one
out the next day annie refuses to come
out of her room yoon-woo sits outside
her door and assures her that her
friends will accept her for who she is
he also confesses that he felt the same
way as them when he first saw her but
has since changed his mind suddenly
annie walks into the house revealing
that she was never in the room yoonwu
embarrassingly greets her and lets her
in annie is confident enough to go to
school the next day she wants to talk to
taihee and solve the problem between
them however in class taihi ignores her
entirely during recess she approaches
her again and apologizes for being a
robot but tai hee calls her scary asking
her to stay away annie is heartbroken by
the rejection she runs outside and
doesn't return home even when it gets
dark by the end of the day tai he has
also told the truth yoon wu then
remembers the dream where he saw annie
running down a dark alley the group
immediately goes to look for her at a
similar place tai he feels awful for
being the reason why annie is missing
meanwhile the stranger who had been
following annie finds her in an alleyway
her battery runs out making her fall
unconscious and giving him the perfect
opportunity to kidnap her but he has to
stop when the group arrives and
threatens to call the police the man
runs away before being caught as the
group tends to an unconscious annie the
following day at school tai hee still
refuses to talk to annie but when she
opens her locker she finds it filled
with her favorite drink and an apology
note that day yoon woo goes out on a
date with seoulgi she senses that he has
been acting weird for the past few days
having known him for five years she
understands his feelings and claims that
they should remain just friends to her
it's totally understandable that yoon
woo wants to hit on a robot instead
after the encounter yoonwu goes to pick
up annie from school and takes her to
the park he offers to carry her bag even
when she claims that it is very heavy he
insists but can hardly lift it up from
the ground on trying as they talk annie
bluntly confesses that she likes him and
kisses him on the cheek a flustered yoon
woo reveals that he feels the same way
later that day yoonwu finds a laptop in
the storeroom on opening it he finds out
that it belongs to his father he plays a
video message from him where he reveals
that annie is a special robot who has
the ability to feel real human emotion
he has embedded their mother's memories
in her processor that subconsciously
affects her thinking which makes her
feel even more human yoon-woo feels like
he only liked danny because she was
mimicking his mother when she arrives
home he accuses her of betraying him and
asks her to go away he doesn't want to
have an aida piss complex annie tells
him that she is not his mother but
yoon-woo refuses to listen she runs away
from the house and is yet again caught
by the strange man this time he comes
forward to fight but is proven weak
against annie's superhuman strength just
then yoon wu also arrives at the scene
to save her as annie sees him and smiles
the man shoots her cut to a month later
annie had to be repaired and rebooted
after the incident which made her lose
her memory yoon woo and minji are sad
but understand that she is needed in the
lab after they leave kevin calls annie
by her scientific name but she corrects
him and claims that her name is annie
revealing that her memory somehow
remained after being rebooted subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like thank you
for watching